AND AWAY WE GO HERE.
RYAN FOR EDMONTON.
PASS BEHIND THE NET.
CUT OFF. OFF.
GOOD FORECHECK BY THE  THE OILE
AND KOSKINEN IS A BEAUTIF'RE LO.
THAT WRISTER BEATSG FURTHER BY .
HYMAN TO NURSE.D DARCY KUEMPER
SENSATIONAL ACROSS.
GETS A GREAT SHOT AWAY.
PULJUJARVI A LITTLE BIT BACK TOO
MUCH INTO KUEMPER WHO HAS TO
S.
BACKHAND PASS.
A SHOT FROMHE AVALANCHE NET
AND COGLIANO.
WHAT ACTION COMPHER.
ANOTHER
IT IS MCDAVID TO NURSE!
OH, BOY.
HE RIFLED THAT  HERE.
DARNELL NURSE.
HE'S LOOKING TO
LEHKONEN THERE AND WHERE ARE
THEY?
COLORANET?
THE 2ND PERIOD
THE EDMONTON OILERS DRAW FIRST H
THIS.
ELEVATES THAT PUCKE
RED LINE.
HE HAS TO HESITATE.FROM KEITH.
THE PUCK IS LATE IN THE 1ST PER.
>> Harnarayan: RYAN
NUGENT-HOPKINS GETTING THE PUCK
F
THE NET.
>> Louie:
FROM NATHAN  PUCK.
LOOK AT
PIECE.
2:35 LEFT
MACKINNON WAITING.
NURSE.
THE TRIO FOR EDMONTON.
ANDOFF.
HIS PASS IN FRONT.
INTERFERENCE?
ALMOST TAKESTHERE.
GIVES IT TO MCDAVID.
MCDAVID. LOW IN
FRONT OF THE NET FOR A
REDIRECTION.
HE WANTS TO SEE
NUGENT-HOPKINS,Y FIGURE IT GOES
INTO THE BENCH THE FAR  IN THE .
STICK HANDLITURN.
MOVING IN FROMOM DOWN THE
DRAISAITL MOVING UP. EDMONTON.
IT IS RANTANEN, TURN.
HE'S MOVOV MAKING THE
SAVE.
AND THAT SEALS THE DEAL.